and we began with a startling new report
suggesting president Trump ignored
advice from key advisors on giving Jared
Kushner access to highly confidential
documents the New York Times reports the
president directed that his son-in-law
and senior adviser receive a top secret
security clearance he reportedly
overruled objections from intelligence
officials the White House chief of staff
and the president's top White House
lawyer Kushner has been at the center of
trade deals with Mexico and has worked
closely with Israel Saudi Arabia and
Egypt to try to secure peace in the
Middle East his attorney says Kushner's
clearance quote was handled in the
regular process with no pressure from
anyone Paul Reid is at the White House
this morning Paula good morning good
morning since the beginning of the
administration Kushner security
clearance has been held up as his
background checks stalled and
intelligence officials expressed concern
that the president's son-in-law could be
vulnerable to foreign influence we've
been working on the peace initiative for
two years now for the past week senior
White House adviser Jared Kushner has
been touring the Middle East showcasing
his prominent role on the international
stage for the trump administration Jerez
done an outstanding job I think he's
been treated very unfairly he's a high
quality person now according to the New
York Times in May of last year the
President ordered former chief of staff
John Kelly to upgrade Kushner from
interim status to top-secret overruling
significant concerns from longtime
intelligence officials Kelly and former
White House Counsel Don Magan the
president denied he was involved in an
interview last month I know that there
was issues back and forth about security
for for numerous people actually but I
don't want to get involved in that stuff
Kushner's wife and advisor to the
president Ivanka Trump also came to her
father's defense the president had no
involvement pertaining to my clearance
or my husband's clearance last February
officials in the White House told CBS
News they were concerned that Kushner
was naive and being tricked in
conversations with foreign officials
some of whom said they only wanted to
deal with Kushner directly and not more
experienced personnel and during the
clearance process Kushner was forced to
update his federal disclosure form
dozens of times
to add foreign contacts including a 2016
meeting with Russian officials in Trump
Tower and conversations with Russian
ambassador Sergey kis lyac we have
control over security clearances top
Democrats are now investigating how some
officials in the White House obtained
their clearances and could subpoena the
White House for more information in a
statement House Oversight Chairman
Elijah Cummings wrote the committee
expects full compliance with its
requests as soon as possible
or it may become necessary to consider
alternative means to compel compliance
holding access to a top-secret security
clearance allows you to see information
that if released officials say could
cause extremely grave damage to national
security
now Cummings says the White House has
not produced a single piece of
information related to its investigation
Alex Paula thank you